welcome to this video playing d from
France try this english defence again
with e 6 + b 6 mm gasps a 3m yeah
probably f5 has the way to go giving
this a Dutch flavor I am you can hear
you can play em with g6 but this is not
bad instantly centralizing the night and
getting the bishop on f6 yeah can i play
this relatively quickly because I I had
this some years ago on a tournament game
quite some pressure here on the center
gather queen is a bit uncomfortable him
but it can play III III yeah he not only
can play that he'd probably will play it
I don't see I Bishop e3 up can play but
should be three maybe
yeah Bishop e3 is maybe a may be good
but he didn't go for it so castles or
yeah maybe this first the rook belongs
on c8 anyway and now but 95 isn't this
annoying attacking c4 and b3 hmm what
are you doing now
I take here I'm winning c4 right if I go
here then you need supply broke a tooth
also ugly okay but this is its winning
the c-4 porn I think okay if I take here
that's 96 but just 27 coming so how do
how do you win the poor now I can take
here actually first if it takes with the
look I play night be three it takes with
the pawn it takes you for hmm but he's
got d5 hmm you have this pitiful but he
cannot play be three of course he cannot
play be three anyway I just take it and
take be three simple yeah even now he
can't play 96 yeah sometimes instead of
talking you should really think yeah
this was stupid yeah was I just I could
just take a sea form also for nothing
but I thought okay well why not castle I
saw this idea but I came so continue
this
yeah yeah of course now it's just the
rain check except for this idea the only
idea in this position check no I'm gonna
piss up but ok you never know what kind
of nonsense I'm i turn my plane should I
go nite see form I can play night b3
even or better better yeah come on let's
let's make some chat some room here for
the king don't know what it for was all
about
hmm and I'll just take it right there's
no new specialist but never threatening
95 yeah of course this was something
more than lucky I just I just white
forfeits due to this connection yeah i
understand it really i play like a
completed yet and then then he gives me
the look for nothing rupee one oops i
can instead of castles yeah i can i can
just take it and no problem like like
this I mean and I just it's a pawn I
mean he can try this this kind of move
but it's I don't know I didn't don't
think it's enough compensation but I
thought okay let's do this especially
nice and take it next move and this of
course is just just over for black after
this night a five assists very good
there's also Bishop a 6cm leading to a
good position and TF this is a good move
also protecting it with the king and
then take yeah this is maybe the best
one can can try that done yeah this is
good for black this is almost trapped
here yeah very lucky game he allowed
this look to be taken for nothing yeah
thanks for watching